أرى هذه الصور
وقد أذهلوني في المرة الأولى التي رأيتها
فيها وأثارت مليون سؤال
حول حقوق الطبع والنشر حول الموافقة
على التحيزات ، أريد أن أتحدث إليكم
عن الفن هنا فن الذكاء الاصطناعي ،
ما رأيك عندما  شاهد ما
يمكن أن تفعله دوللي 2
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ،
لا تعتقد أبدًا أنه فن أو لا ،
إنها أداة ، إنها أداة مثل قلم رصاص
،
لا تنسى الكاميرا في القرن التاسع عشر أن
أكثر العقول ذكاءً على قيد الحياة قالت إن
الكاميرا ستنتهي
الفن بالطبع لم ينته الفن ، بل امتد إلى
البشر ، لذا ما أراه عندما أرى
هذه الصور
هو أن ترى أولاً صورًا تعتقد
أنها كلب ممل لشخص ما أو تعرف
فصيل كورجي أو رسم قديم لطائر من
الذي تعرف أودوبون  أو متجرًا
ولكن الحقيقة هي أنه عندما تعرض الفن
ما يسمى أريدك أن تسأل هل هو فن جيد
أم فن سيء ،
أود أن أقول إن ما أظهرته لي حتى
الآن مثل هذا وقضاعة بناءً على رسم توضيحي قديم
لقضاعة  فيرمير فتاة
ذات طبقات من اللؤلؤ وما إلى ذلك
هذا توضيح كرابولا جميل
، ليس لديه خيال
أو
إبداع إذا كان بإمكانهم برمجة
شيء مثل
مارسيل بروست
يمشي عبر
شهادة دقيقة في نيويورك
أو نهاية الحضارة
وجعلها تبدو وكأنها لا تبدو وكأنها نوع
نموذجي
من
شيء بخاري أو فن نفت.
هذا ما أود رؤيتك